sonic looks objectively better this is
the very first cgi character on film oh
is he a surfeit
green screen
so the biggest thing that was changed
thanks to trade for sponsoring today's
video stay tuned to the end so you can
find out how you can save 30 off your
first coffee
hi welcome back to another episode of
vfx artist react we have a special
emergency segment we have to do because
the new sonic trailer just dropped and
you know what vfx artists react was born
from the ashes of the old sonic trailer
it's disgusting so let's do it guys
[Music]
sonic looks objectively better yeah he's
cute look at those eyes man it's all
about the eyes they were all beady
before he feels more appropriate like
he's a cartoon character remember his
teeth remember his human teeth he was
awesome just so emotionless and now he
actually has emotion yeah he's goofy
they've shown a lot more of the movie in
this trailer the first trailer is
lacking a lot of the humor and just like
quirkiness that this one has
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go did he dead just like impaled
so the biggest thing that was changed
were the eyes and they're more
expressive but they also dialed back the
fur yeah actually i noticed that
so if you look at this before and after
which is a pretty amazing photo in and
of itself
oh my god
we were dealing with
you'll see he still has like the fur
going up and over his eyebrows here but
in the original design you can see all
the highlights the individual actual
pairs specifically are capturing
technically the quills oh okay
they also gave sonic actual gloves
versus just white fairy hands big overly
exaggerated sized shoes
and socks the other thing that stands
out to me the green of his eyes i
wondered if you're going to mention it
the greenie of his eyes is way more
saturated than the most saturated green
that's in the scene it's it's a less
saturated less saturated and it's a
little bit warmer look at the tone of
the green of his eyes the green and the
rubber bands but they're all in the same
color space in fact the most saturated
thing is is blue and even then the blue
kind of rolls off to desaturation as it
gets brighter towards the edges of his
head it's much more accurately mimicking
the color response of the camera you
need to obey the physical rules of your
camera with your cg footage if you want
to look real so when we broke down the
first sonic trailer we talked about the
bloom from lightning that blue glow from
the lightning the camera would never
capture it like that even though the
camera's exposed way down to the point
where the clouds aren't even white
there's still glow coming through that
electricity which you wouldn't get so
bloom happens when a light is so bright
that it diffuses as it goes through the
lens of the camera and also as it hits
some of the other elements as well it's
like if we look at the old sonic the
hedgehog trailer there's a ton of bloom
on that lightning now if we look at the
new sonic and we look at that lightning
the bloom is brought way more down so
the lightning is bright but it's not
like it's any brighter than the sun or
the sky that's you know giving us
brightness behind it in fact you can
kind of see the lightning over the sky
right there and it's just a little bit
brighter in the sky
on top of you know recreating sonic
himself i do think they ended up
probably having to scrap all the
original animation because i don't think
you can just retarget the skeleton to
this new model especially since it seems
most of the animation is in the face
yeah not to mention even if you could
retarget the animation it's been a whole
character redesign it's as if they
recast them like yeah the new sonic is
way more expressive and way more
cartoony and you can't just your old
animation if it's not cartoony and that
expressive it's not just going to
transfer a lot of people online were
kind of concerned that they're having a
redesigned sonic that means all these
artists are going to end up being
overworked trying to like crunch and
have to scrap everything
but they also delayed the release of
this movie by over four months
so they actually finished shooting this
movie in october of 2018 that gives them
approximately four or five months to do
all the effects that ended up going into
the trailer usually when the first
trailer for a movie drops
all the effects you see are literally
pretty much the only effects that have
been completed up until that point so
it's about the same amount of time that
they had
that was added on top of it so as far as
an overall production schedule things
got shifted
rather well i'm happy to see that
there's an improvement i'm happy to see
that they're actually making good use of
the time
i hope we didn't hurt their feelings too
bad with our very first vfx artist react
video i don't think we were nearly as
mean as the rest of the internet were
it's disgusting and now we're going to
switch clothes for no reason clint have
you ever seen young sherlock holmes
before no of course not okay let's just
see what your thoughts are okay
all right this movie came out in 1985.
whoa whoa
whoa that's awesome
man that must have been mind-blowing so
clint this is the very first cgi
character on film ever made kind of
really i mean they had cgi characters
they had done but this is the first one
where it's a cgi character
into live action photography yeah dude
oh this is sick oh this is great like
they're not trying to make something
that looks real dude the way it jumps
out of the stained glass window is
awesome it's like warping and then it
just
and also notice the motion blur that was
like brand new technology motion blur
yeah
and it was all just through coding
they're like uh frame here frame here
interpolate everything in between and
blur it out look at that it's got
shadows it's good yeah it has shadows
the shadows they weren't able to render
the shadows back then they didn't have
any sort of system for shadows so those
shadows were actually hand animated yeah
into the scene this was a groundbreaking
visual effect at the time this was
actually pioneered by dennis mirren and
john lasseter dennis mirren who is a
legend of visual effects he has the most
academy awards of any living person on
the planet he's also the first visual
effects artist to ever receive an
academy award and john lasseter is the
man who went on to found pixel exactly
in fact this uh scene right here they
spent six months working on the 10
seconds of footage you see of the
stained glass man they pioneered a whole
bunch of new uh rendering techniques
they actually like sculpted some of
these pieces in clay and used a
polyphenous three space
digitizer it's basically a wand that you
basically move it through 3d space and
it records point coordinates like a
photo scanner it's a super rudimentary
version of that you're literally just
getting coordinates though because back
in the day when they're doing 3d
animation like there was no autodesk
there was no maya there was no cinema 4d
there was no blender what the heck did
they do they literally made it
themselves like they're using raw math
yeah they're doing like coding for this
oh my god you had to sit there do the
math for all the translations of all the
vector points and then punch it in the
computer and wait a while and hopefully
it looks okay i mean you can do 3d
modeling with a pencil and paper by
writing out x y and z coordinates and
plotting them and that's to the point
what they're doing here with that model
and john lasseter actually painted all
of what you see there he painted the
texture map for the night so ilm
actually did the effects for this movie
and shortly after this movie came out it
was a bit of a lackluster box office
release they actually sold that section
of the company to steve jobs and that's
what became pixar and shortly after this
they did a whole short film that won
like 30 awards and that went on to
become like the very famous pixar logo
so real quick we have 2 million 971 000
subscribers right now oh wow we are 29
000 subscribers away from 3
million holy crap 42 and a half percent
of people that watch this channel are
not subscribed if you are not subscribed
and you subscribe now you can help us
hit 3 million and we will have a really
cool party really
sweet
oh it's the flash tv show okay
dude
that's how you run if you're a robot
he's a terminator
this selection doesn't look too bad for
a tv show oh
yeah this way that's pretty is that all
cg i think that's all cg i think that's
that was entirely cg that's awesome
whoa that was
one look at the face as usual but it's
pretty sweet yeah it's nice this is
pretty sweet so far like that one shot
was a little ballsy to make it 100 cg
but all the other stuff looked pretty
good the only thing that got me was the
camera movement you have no bounds you
can place the camera anywhere and do
anything movie magic i do kind of like
the orange glow effects though yeah
right here you can see the light
flickering casting shadow all over the
place on the windowsill to have the cg
light animated with the flickering
lightning really makes the cg look good
and brings the scenes to life but then
the second thing is they have real shots
they have lightning in so they had to go
and paint the light in by hand and they
did a really good job of it this one
decent looking not too bad but this one
when the guy runs up looks really good
with the way the light is casting the
ground and the walls around him they did
a great job blending the light it casts
the shadows nicely the guy's foot the
flash is like left foot that's sitting
on the ground still gets a little bit of
shadow cast from the orange light but
it's like oh yeah you're soft and
rounded out well the super subtle camera
shake just like a little just the
tiniest of rumbles yeah really elevates
the shot with a certain amount of energy
that it really needs for someone coming
out of light speed so how would you guys
compare this to the shots from supergirl
that we looked at like a week ago this
is like leagues better league's better
yeah this like actually not that bad but
also the filmmaking's quite a bit better
too it's not just about like adding
effects onto something it's also like
how are the effects motivated from the
filmmaking perspective so compared to
supergirl where there's like awkward
reanimated retime stuff the camera's all
like doing really cool stuff the
rendering's great they're using like
good photo real rendering and good like
lighting techniques it definitely feels
like there's a bit of a budget priority
here so all in all nice work the flash
i've seen some stuff that's a little on
the cg side but you know what do like
full cg characters for tv shows kind of
gutsy i gotta commend them for it shows
are hard to do visual effects for
because the budget is way more stretched
out
lose them
get him a
bartail oh adventures of tintin didn't
spielberg direct this faster you idiot
faster is that spielberg
[Laughter]
that tank is driving a building by the
way guys it hasn't cut yet yeah i did
notice that this is all one long take we
thought our boss town renders were long
the reason one take here is not trivial
is because think about a video game you
only have so many textures so many
characters on the screen at the same
time because there's only a certain
amount of memory in your computer when
it comes to 3d animation you can usually
access more computers memory but there's
still only a limited amount of memory in
your computer so how do you have a world
that has 100 characters in it a thousand
buildings 800 physics simulations with
smoke and water and all that kind of
stuff fountains all over the place
clothing simulations all over the place
like how do you bring that all together
in one shot and that's one of the most
technically impressive things about this
is that it's element after element after
element all being set up individually
and then being brought together in what
looks like one long shot basically
artists have to go in and then little by
little they build up pieces of it on
like individual simulations or setups or
environments and they render them all
out one by one they just put it all
together layer by layer
here's all the high level things
happening in this thing we have rigid
body physics aka hard things that bounce
off of each other we have cloth physics
we have soft body physics with the paper
we have feather physics water surface
water you have splashes and you have
foam foam simulation is another thing
that's kind of crazy a lot of people
take for granted rag dolls as characters
being influenced by each other we have
hand animation and mocap animation that
needs to drive physics but one isn't
physics and the other one is so it's
really easy to break things curry powder
we have curry powder simulation good
voice simulation good boy simulation we
have exhilarating story simulation
if you guys have a movie that has some
cool visual effects you're like how did
they do that go ahead and leave a
comment on what that movie is we'll see
it we'll read it and we'll react to it
right here because we love reacting to
vfx
wait is this this is the one with the
the space the space laser this is gears
of war this is gears of war
what was that
oh the camera's moving in
no
oh this is the worst
this is the worst so they're slowing
this down and they're only doing so by
duplicating a frame so you see how it's
like move move stop move move stop move
loose stop what's happening here is
you're seeing a slow motion shot but
it's clearly fake digital slow motion
because the camera motion itself is
still at 24 frames per second even
though the shot itself is at like 18 or
16 frames per second
oh what's what plan does james bond have
here snowboard son triple black diamond
oh he's gonna surf it
[Applause]
oh boy this doesn't look very good well
the water actually looks pretty good it
does the ice looks super fake and then
right here
he just did like a body lift with his
arms from here yeah there yeah
as if going off a jump somehow makes
your parachute go up with you
wait
that's a great point
so a couple things that stand out to me
visually on this thing one the super cg
ice just like blatantly cgi cg ice the
shadows are a little weird the green
screening
the green you can always tell we're
going through the screen honestly that's
the thing that like kind of falls apart
for me most are all the these close-up
shots of pierce brosnan which i get you
got to have the reaction shots of your
hero but it's just so obviously like
disassociated from what's happening
behind him he looks like a weather man
in front of a like a green screen
pointing at like and over here we got
flooding and ice everything is blue by
the way in the frame except for that
yellow parachute i guess and then if you
go to pierce brosnan nothing's blue he
has no blue light no blue edge yeah and
there's some just awkward light wrap
being improperly used so light wrap a
really handy tool really common tool for
green screening basically it's to wrap
some light from your background around
your actor the problem is light wrap
only makes sense when something behind
you is bright so for example the sky
should be blooming or glowing and that
should be the light wrap around his arm
but there's nothing bright on the bottom
right or the bottom left for that matter
and we're still getting light wrap which
just really makes it feel like you're
watching a bunch of filters being put on
footage in after effects so all those
blue glaciers and pieces of ice rushing
by especially the bright white ones that
are reflecting a lot of light we should
be seeing these colored lights basically
whooshing by pierce brosnan's face and
all you need to do is on set have you
know when your gaffers take light and
kind of go like this or like move a
reflector around but there's none of
that happening with pierce bros in here
what was the scene we just watched what
was with his legs like he was like gonna
land it
and he was like nah i'm gonna like
and he's like okay i'll land it like
what
trade is
all right guys we're here to talk to you
about trade coffee now they sent us a
bunch of boxes and we're gonna crack
them open here and we're gonna tell you
about the smells oh i got the chronic
super dank
super today coffee i got without the
love
metric yeah i'm going to open this up i
want to actually like smell this coffee
visual effects artists react to coffee
smells here we go
oh
it smelled a little sweet and then i
looked on the side of the bag and it
said maple
ah reminds me of a library it's got that
comforting warm feeling
smells like i'm kayaking through the
bayou so the roasters actually ethically
source these beans and the supply chain
is set up in such a way that the money
actually makes it back to the farmers
themselves oh nice yeah so i'm not a big
coffee drinker meaning i don't really
know much about the flavor profiles of
coffee one of the cool things about this
company is that when you sign up you
take a survey and the company will send
you coffees that are tailored to your
taste so whether you're just starting
with coffee or you are very experienced
you know exactly what you like these
guys will send you different types of
roasts from different companies that
will match what flavor profiles you are
looking for trade is giving the first
250 people who click the link in the
description below 30 off their first
copy just use the code corridor so big
thanks to trade for sponsoring this
video you guys can check out more about
them in the description down below all
right quick game whoever has the bag
fall off their head last gets to keep
all this coffee go
oh
clint gets it no
no
nico it's good to have you back i've
been here the whole time
i don't know why i said that you're the
one who went to texas for ten days i
know it's good to be back thanks for
having me guys hope you guys enjoyed
that vfx reaction episode where um you
know i'm just basically just saying
stuff and you're never going to use this
footage thank you for watching i hope
you are subscribed if you're not
subscribed please consider doing so holy
crap we're almost at 3 million
subscribers if i pause for a second and
look back on this year it's been crazy
so many of you are new people to this
channel thank you for watching so many
of you have subscribed thank you so much
many of you have commented anyways i'll
stop now it's just been awesome i can't
wait to share more visual effects
knowledge with all of you